on the weekend I don't wear socks I have
to wear socks to work can I can I take
can I leave my socks at home okay don't
you wear socks you're gonna get blisters
you got too much on it's so high you
understand me I don't want you walking
around the school with that you're gonna
perspire and you're gonna get sick tie
your shoelace right now these are my
kids I share them with their parents but
they're my kids there's a hat on your
head there's a hat on your head thank
you and there's nothing in the world I
won't do for them they're like my blood
they are Jeff led is the superintendent
of icon charter schools a network of
seven small schools in the South Bronx
we're about 80 percent of the kids come
from poor homes I told my kids the only
time you're gonna see a courthouse is
when you're an attorney or a judge and
the only time you're gonna see the
inside of police station is if you're
wearing a uniform though you'll rarely
read or hear about it icon is one of the
nation's most successful charter school
networks the students here do
exceptionally well on the state English
and math exams far outpacing both the
kids at traditional public schools in
New York and those who attend the other
leading charter school networks but this
isn't lits first big success educating
kids in the South Bronx years before he
came to icon lit served as the principal
of a public elementary school called PS
67 later renamed mohegan when he arrived
at the school in 1988 it was a disaster
the walls in the hallway were covered
with graffiti and urine it was probably
the worst teaching staff that New York
City had yet like all public school
principals at that time lit had very
little power to make changes it was
dictated to me what my staffing was
going to be but then I was responsible
for the outcomes in this school I was
not allowed to pick a textbook
nevertheless in short order he replaced
almost the entire teaching staff brought
in a rigorous new curriculum and
rehabilitated the school building I
wasn't granted permission to make any of
the changes that I did I just did it lit
left Mohegan in 1997 and then three
years later billionaire investor Carl
Icahn donated money to create one of the
city's first
charter schools and he hired lit to
design it from the ground up icons money
would go exclusively to pay for
buildings and there would be less money
spent on each student than at a
traditional public school but that
didn't matter for the first time in his
career lit was given a free hand I used
to say I was like a horse in a Corral
and suddenly you opened up the door and
the horse could run free and show how
fast they could really run though icon
was a runaway success lit was programmed
early in his career not to rankle the
public education bureaucracy that he
runs circles around we stay under the
radar our culture is non-confrontational
another reason Icahn gets so little
attention is that it's been overshadowed
by another charter school network which
is anything but non confrontational if
Jeff let stands for the old guard in New
York City's Charter School world Eva
Moskowitz the founder and CEO of Success
Academy represents the new mosque whatsa
sees the bully pulpit loudly denouncing
the mayor the school's chancellor and
the teachers union for trapping children
in terrible schools and success
academies test scores have given her a
loud megaphone Icahn is the number two
highest achieving charter network in New
York second to Success Academy but the
comparison between the two organizations
gets more hazy when you take into
account what's known as impact killing
when students leave Success Academy
schools for whatever reason the
administration stops replacing them with
new students after the fourth grade so
the enrollment of each class dwindles
over the years icon on the other hand
replaces the kids who leave with new
students from the district schools
generally those students have a lot of
catching up to do and they bring down
icons overall scores and while success
has been widely criticized for often
suspending students and stigmatizing low
achievers icon has a less punitive
atmosphere last year 11 percent of
students at the Success Academy schools
were suspended at least once at ICON
half a percent were suspended or a total
of ten kids among all seven schools the
best way to describe it is unconditional
love I think it's no fluke that they're
the two highest performing charter
networks in your
charles psalm is the education policy
director at the manhattan institute and
he's been researching and writing about
both Success Academy and Icahn he says
the reason they've done so well it's
sort of a no-brainer I think both of
them focus like a laser beam on what
kids are actually being taught and how
and keeping kids up on grade level if
they're falling behind a certain area
getting getting them extra help it
sounds very simple but actually doing it
is quite difficult and rare icons
teachers tend to be more experienced
than those in other charter schools and
many of lits administrators are veterans
of the traditional public school system
who he lured out of retirement by
offering them the opportunity for the
first time in their careers to do their
jobs unimpeded by union work roles and
red tape
soon after Marcie Gladstein retired as
the principal of a traditional public
school in the Bronx she got a call from
Jeff litt offering her a chance to be a
principal yet again and one of the
schools in the icon Network now you can
practice what you've been taught now
kids can really benefit from your
experience I want your imagination I
want your creativity
I couldn't imagine the heights that I
could go when I could do whatever I
wanted to do how did they clean their
feathers if I have an idea and I want to
do it it is done and there's no
questions asked principal Lawford
cunningham also started his career at a
traditional public school but he didn't
leave voluntarily he was pushed out
after its first year because he hadn't
completed his master's degree
coincidentally Marcie Gladstein was his
first boss so what happened was I got a
call from the district office telling me
that he no longer had a job when he was
more qualified then teachers that I had
but because they had seniority they were
allowed to remain in my building while
he actually was fired it feels like you
don't have control over your own
organization so I hired mr. Cunningham
and
Deas I don't know two three inches
taller than me
looks like his carved out of stone every
single year 100% of his kids passed the
exam so lit promoted him to staff
developer and then four years ago to
principal of the fifth school in the
icon Network my personality is stern and
put together have a seat have a seat
have a seat I mean I get that from out
my dad and all the males in my life
they're all respected yeah but you have
to eat something when I have to go get
Apple we're not really concerned about
the press we're not concerned about that
aspect of it we do the right thing we
make sure that I was stood in school two
specialized high schools and that's our
focus
but while Success Academy is growing
fast thanks to its aggressive approach
the icon network has expanded much more
slowly
even though families are desperate to
win a spot this year the sixteen
thousand five hundred and thirteen kids
who applied to go to one of the icon
schools at less than a 1% chance of
getting in that's sixteen thousand five
hundred and thirteen parents who turned
that back on the goe they said I don't
want you I want them
a parent in the inner-city who wants the
same for her child that we all want for
hours she's trapped and she knows not
too much is gonna come out of that
school to help her child escape that
cycle of poverty so charter schools came
in and now a parent has a chance of not
sending the child to that neighborhood
school that's unsuccessful the problem
is we don't have enough charter schools
how you doing over there you okay yeah
waiting to go home okay